tomemos una reacción en la que a más p
nos da nuestros productos y la letra
minúscula a y la letra minúscula be
representa los coeficientes de nuestra
ecuación balanceada y si nos ponemos a
pensar un poco
qué pasa si aumentamos la concentración
de nuestros reactivos a y b si
hiciéramos eso a ive estarían más juntos
en el espacio y por lo tanto sería más
probable que reaccionarán y de esa forma
aumentaría la velocidad de la reacción y
bueno esto es cierto para la mayoría de
las reacciones si aumentas la
concentración de los reactivos aumentas
la velocidad de la reacción y de hecho
se puede comprobar experimentalmente ok
digamos por ejemplo que queremos saber
cuál es el efecto de la concentración
del reactivo
en la velocidad de la reacción entonces
lo que vamos a hacer es dejar la
concentración debe constante
y hacer varios experimentos en los que
la concentración de a cambio y fijarnos
en cuál es la velocidad de la reacción
en todos esos experimentos ok pero
siempre dejando la concentración debe
constante otra cosa importante que hay
que mencionar es que vamos a utilizar la
velocidad inicial aunque hay porque
entre más tiempo dejemos que suceda la
reacción los productos van a tener una
mayor concentración y como algunas
reacciones son reversibles eso puede
provocar muchos cambios en la velocidad
de reacción y eso está muy interesante
pero no es lo que queremos observar
ahorita ok más bien lo que queremos
hacer es ver cómo la concentración de
nuestros reactivos afecta a la velocidad
de la reacción y por eso utilizamos la
velocidad inicial donde únicamente
tenemos reactivos y no tenemos productos
entonces pues vamos a ver el primer
experimento en el primer experimento la
concentración de a
un molar y en este experimento con esta
concentración de a la velocidad inicial
de la reacción es 0.01 molares sobre
segundo entonces ese fue el primer
experimento vamos con el segundo
experimento en el segundo experimento lo
que vamos a hacer es dejar la
concentración debe constante pero
aumentar la concentración de a que ahí
vamos a poner una concentración de 2
molar y en estas condiciones donde la
concentración de a es 2 molar y la
concentración debe se quedó constante la
velocidad inicial de la reacción es de
0.02 molares sobre segundo lo que
hicimos en este experimento fue
incrementar la concentración de
al doble o sea multiplicando la por 2
porque estamos comparando estos dos
experimentos y lo que pasó al aumentar
al doble la concentración de a fue que
la velocidad inicial aumentó también al
doble que entonces la velocidad inicial
de la reacción aumentó por un factor de
2 bueno y ahora lo que vamos a hacer es
comparar el primer experimento con el
tercer experimento crear y hemos
incrementado la concentración de a de un
molar a tres molares entonces
incrementamos la concentración de a por
un factor de 3 y ahora qué es lo que
pasó con la velocidad inicial de la
reacción pues la velocidad inicial
aumentó de 0.01 a 0.03 o sea que la
velocidad inicial de la reacción aumentó
por un factor de 3
y ahora para encontrar la relación lo
que tenemos que hacer es pensar que este
número elevado a qué potencia nos da
este número de aquí hay dos a la que nos
va a dar dos pues 2 a la 1 es igual a 2
2 a la 1 es igual a 2 y también lo
pudimos haber hecho para nuestra otra
comparación de dos experimentos macri 3
a la que nos da 3 pues el exponente
también tiene que ser 1 cierto porque 3
a la 1 es igual a 3 y entonces la
velocidad de la reacción es proporcional
a la concentración de a
elevado a la potencia uno que haya
elevado a la potencia 1 y ahora vamos a
hacer exactamente lo mismo pero con la
concentración de b queremos saber qué
tanto afecta a la concentración del
reactivo ve a la velocidad de esta
reacción así es que lo que hacemos es
dejar la concentración del reactivo a
constante y hacemos tres experimentos en
los que vamos cambiando la concentración
debe y nos fijamos en qué valores toma
la velocidad inicial de estas reacciones
porque dejamos constante la
concentración de a y de esa forma
podemos ver el impacto de la
concentración de ve en la velocidad
inicial en el primer experimento tenemos
que la concentración debe es un molar y
la velocidad inicial de la reacción es
0.01 molares por segundo después en el
segundo experimento aumentamos la
concentración de b
ahora tiene una concentración 2 molar y
entonces hacemos las observaciones de
nuestro experimento y observamos que la
velocidad inicial de la reacción con
esta concentración debe es de 0.04
molares por segundo
así es que aumentamos la concentración
debe de un molar a dos molares o sea que
la aumentamos por un factor de 2 y que
es lo que observamos en los experimentos
acerca de la velocidad inicial pues
observamos que hubo un incremento de la
velocidad inicial de la reacción de 0.01
a 0.04 o sea que hubo un incremento de
un factor 4 y ahora vamos a comparar el
primer experimento con el tercer
experimento aumentamos la concentración
de 1 molar a 3 molar lo que aumentamos
la concentración debe por un factor de 3
y nos preguntamos qué pasó con la
velocidad inicial de estas reacciones
como podemos observar la velocidad
inicial de estos experimentos aumentó de
0.01 a 0.09 molares por segundo
así es que hubo un incremento en la
velocidad inicial por un factor 9 y
entonces ahora nos preguntamos dos a qué
potencia que vamos a decir que la
potencia para distinguirlo de esta otra
potencia pero 2 elevado a qué exponente
nos da 4 y aquí la respuesta es 2 porque
2 a las 2 es igual a 4 y también nos
podemos preguntar 3 elevado a cual
exponente es igual a 9 y bueno pues 3
elevado a las 2 es igual a 9 entonces
hemos determinado que la velocidad de la
reacción es proporcional
a la concentración debe elevada a la
segunda potencia ya ahora podemos poner
estas dos cosas juntas para escribir lo
que se conoce como la ley de la
velocidad o también conocida como la
ecuación cinética que hay entonces vamos
a necesitar más espacio sabemos que la
velocidad de la reacción es proporcional
a la concentración del reactivo a
elevado a la 1 y también es proporcional
a la concentración de b elevado al
cuadrado y luego ponemos por aquí una
constante que se le llama el coeficiente
de velocidad o también lo podemos llamar
constante cinética o constante de
velocidad y esto es la ley de la
velocidad o ecuación cinética pero vamos
por partes la r mayúscula es la
velocidad de la reacción velocidad
de reacción
la k es la constante cinética pero
también se le conoce como constante de
velocidad y creo que ese es el término
que vamos a utilizar en general por aquí
instante de velocidad
y es algo súper importante saber que la
velocidad de la reacción no es lo mismo
que la constante de velocidad
si cambiamos la constante de velocidad
la velocidad de la reacción cambia pero
si cambiamos por ejemplo las
concentraciones de los reactivos cambia
la velocidad de la reacción pero la
constante de velocidad no cambia no
crear y la constante de velocidad es
constante y no cambia aunque es
importante mencionar que si la
temperatura cambia está constante
también cambia pero bueno eso lo vamos a
ver en otro vídeo ahora por acá tenemos
la concentración del reactivo a elevado
a la potencia 1 y por eso decimos que la
reacción es de primer orden en primer
orden en
y por acá podemos observar que las
reacciones del segundo orden
segundo orden en b porque estamos
elevando a la segunda potencia a la
concentración de b y bueno también
podemos hablar acerca del orden total de
la reacción porque tenemos un primer
orden en a y un segundo orden en b y
entonces el orden total de la reacción
es igual a 1 + 2 aunque yo sea 3 el
orden total de la reacción es 3 bueno
ahora vamos hasta arriba y por acá vamos
a escribir una ley de la velocidad
general que ahí tenemos que la velocidad
de la reacción es igual a la constante
de velocidad por la concentración del
reactivo a elevado a un exponente que lo
estamos escribiendo de forma general por
la concentración del reactivo b elevado
a otro exponente
esta es la ley de la velocidad general y
la razón por la que le escribí por aquí
es para decirte que no puedes
simplemente tomar los coeficientes de su
ecuación balanceada y ponerlos por aquí
en los exponentes ok esto no funciona
así tienes que conocer la reacción y
estos exponentes estos órdenes tienen
que ser calculados experimentalmente lo
que tienes que hacer por lo menos dos
experimentos y observar los datos que
obtienes y otra cosa curiosa es que
estos órdenes determinan la unidad que
utiliza la constante de velocidad y
vamos para abajo otra vez
entonces por aquí vamos a determinar
cuáles unidades está usando la constante
de velocidad en este ejemplo la
velocidad de la reacción está en molares
por segundo y queremos encontrar la
unidad de acá luego tenemos que la
concentración del reactivo
se mide en molares y la estamos elevando
a la potencia 1 y luego la concentración
del reactivo b también se miden molares
pero la estamos elevando a la potencia 2
entonces tenemos aquí esta ecuación y
queremos despejar acá si es que por aquí
podríamos cancelar molar con molar
y nos queda uno en tres segundos uno en
tres segundos y pasamos el molar al
cuadrado dividiendo
molares al cuadrado que pues también se
puede escribir como uno entre molares al
cuadrado por segundo y entonces esta es
la unidad que lleva esta constante de
velocidad locker y que es la constante
de velocidad de esta reacción que tiene
un orden total de 3 pero como podemos
observar las unidades de la constante de
velocidad cambian dependiendo del orden
total de la reacción bueno vamos a ver
otro ejemplo
en esta reacción tenemos un solo
reactivo que se transforma en todos
nuestros productos y en el primer
experimento tenemos una concentración de
nuestro reactivo de un molar y hemos
observado que la velocidad inicial de
esta reacción cuando la concentración de
a es de un molar es 0.01 molares por
segundo ahora en nota experimento
aumentamos la concentración de a al
doble pero la velocidad inicial sigue
siendo exactamente la misma entonces
aunque aumentamos la concentración de a
de un molar a dos molares lo que
aumentamos la concentración de a al
doble o sea por un factor 2 la velocidad
inicial de la reacción se mantiene
constante osea podríamos decir que por
un factor 1 entonces nos preguntamos 2
elevado a qué potencia nos da igual a 1
y entonces nos damos cuenta que x tiene
que ser igual a 0 porque 2 a la 0 es 1
cualquier número elevado a la 0 es 1 y
entonces la reacción es de orden 0
ok el orden total de esta reacción es 0
en a y entonces si queremos escribir la
ley de la velocidad tenemos que la
velocidad de la reacción es igual a la
constante de velocidad por la
concentración del reactivo a que es el
único reactivo elevado al orden de este
reactivo que es 0 y entonces esto se
convierte en un 1 y nos queda que la
velocidad de la reacción es igual a la
constante de velocidad y si ahora
quisiéramos saber cuáles son las
unidades de la constante de velocidad de
esta reacción pues sabemos que la
velocidad de la reacción se mide en
molares por segundo y entonces la
constante de velocidad de esta reacción
se tiene que medir en molares por
segundo
así es que tenemos aquí un ejemplo de
como las unidades de la constante de
velocidad cambian dependiendo del orden
total de tu reacción